[Música]
había siete candidatos en el plató pero
el foco del debate del jueves por la
noche Se centró en dos archi rivales el
actual presidente de extrema derecha a
Jair bolsonaro y el ex presidente
izquierdista Luis Ignacio ludada Silva
no Perdieron el tiempo para intercambiar
ataques acusándose mutuamente de
corrupción
es una locura Que un presidente del país
venga aquí y diga lo que dice con el
mayor descaro
por eso el 2 de octubre el pueblo lo
enviará a su casa
no tienes nada contra mi gobierno nada
Deja de mentir y siente vergüenza Lula
nula que estuvo al frente de Brasil
entre 2003 y 2010 Busca regresar a la
presidencia apenas cuatro años después
de haber sido enviado a prisión por
corrupción condenas que fueron anuladas
el año pasado el político de 76 años
aventajados en las encuestas pero el
presidente goza del apoyo fiel de
evangélica y empresarial y muchos
votantes aún no se han decidido por un
candidato Espero que quien se convierta
en presidente de Brasil lo haga bien
sin bromas ni corrupción Mientras tanto
el intento de reelección del titular
recibió un impulso de celebridades el
jueves cuando la superestrella del
fútbol Neymar publicó un video en tiktok
en el que el delantero brasileño baila
una canción de campaña a favor de
bolsonaro
más de 156 millones de brasileños
acudirán a las urnas el domingo para la
primera vuelta sin ningún candidato
tiene más del 50% de los votos Entonces
los dos contendientes con mayor
participación se enfrentarán el 30 de
octubre